Justice a new Department of Justice
report I should say found children who
need Behavioral Health Services in our
state are facing discrimination and
unnecessary segregation thank you for
joining us at four I'm Kirsten Joyce and
I'm Christian cost that is not enough of
these services are here according to the
report parents are then forced to admit
their children into institutional
settings like hospitals and residential
treatment facilities states away it's a
violation of the Americans with
Disability Act reporter Ryan Matthey
joins us live now in studio with the
strain the situation places on families
here in the valley Ryan yeah Kirsten
Christian you want to take a look at
this map right here it's part of the
most recent of Mental Health America
report Nevada you can see in the dark
blue our state ranks fifth for children
who have at least one major depressive
episode each year and this next map that
keeps Nevada in the dark blue as you can
see where nearly five percent more than
the national average for youth with
depression who did not receive mental
health treatment it's an ongoing problem
that this Federal report shines light
cotton
seventeen-year-old Jesse Simpson is not
like most kids it's like someone killed
a crap he was born with Cerebral Palsy
and autism at just 25 weeks that's on
top of significant anxiety and PTSD all
provoking years worth of constant
medical treatment that's what he's known
his childhood is pain his mother Crystal
Simpson says first diagnosing mental
disabilities took a year the waitlist to
get other necessary Behavioral Services
took just as long she says and she was
left with a choice admit him to a
Medical Institution in Utah potentially
for months at a time or drive him there
multiple times a year herself she chose
the latter why should we segregate them
off and treat them like it was back in
the 40s the Department of Justice report
finding hundreds of Nevada families
facing this dilemma it says the state
does not have an adequate amount of
community-based services that could keep
them here at home a quarter of these
children staying away for over a year as
parents we have choices but in Nevada
we've had less choices jar Frost is the
Statewide family Network director for
Nevada pep a resource to help families
navigate their children's mental
disabilities a lack of local Behavioral
Services forced her to submit her own 12
year old child to an out-of-state
institution years ago now she and other
officials expecting change in Nevada's
youth mental health system when kids are
at home and they're doing well mentally
they do better at school
they do better with relationships with
others you know there's just a whole lot
of benefits that come along with being
at home versus being put into a hospital
there needs to be more doctors that can
do this stuff and there's not
now we don't know specifically how many
children that the state require in the
state rather that require these services
and could be benefiting for them to be
closer to home but for Nevada pep here
in Las Vegas alone they say they've
served over 19
000 people in just 2021 reporting live
in studio Ryan Matthey 8 News Now
well Governor Steve sisalak responded to
the doj investigation agreeing that the
state is lacking in-home services
respite crisis services and more are
just a few mentioned in the report now
he did not address how he will
specifically address how he will bring
more of them to Nevada communities